in one of the videos you say the only
solution is for Israel to Annex the Gaza
Strip and kill enough sons of [__] to
make sure this isn't a problem again you
say anyone who calls for a ceasefire is
a terrorist sympathizer I want you to
think about how sick and demented that
is how sick and demented that is the
case that you none of your colleagues or
you have been able to offer one single
condolence one single condemnation one
single word of sympathy whether they
will have power whether they will have
clean water whether they will have
medicine when you occupy a people for
decades and I say that as someone who is
Jewish I'm a Jewish assalam alaykum
greetings of Peace welcome to the de
show I'm Eddie your host thank you for
tuning in it's good to see you guys
excited to have my next guest Dr Omar
sulan an Imam out of Texas a person
who's very well acquainted with what's
happening in Palestine ultimately one of
the things that I think people need to
remember is that if you live in Gaza and
I was reporting there for many years and
have spent time there since the last 15
or so years for the majority of
Palestinians there there's 2 and a half
million of them roughly it's a blockade
imposed by Israel and Egypt and that
means basically you don't have freedom
of movement you can't leave when you
want you can't say study outside the
country very easily and that's
suffocating and this is not a defense of
Hamas by any means I've spent time with
Hamas as a reporter in Gaza are many
gazans I know don't like Hamas
particularly in the past or now but the
truth is that when you occupy a people
for decades and I say that as someone
who is Jewish I'm a Jewish German
Australian and I've reported on this
issue for 20 or so years that I am
surprised by obviously the timing of
this but at the same time not at all
surprised by the reasons behind it that
somehow there's a belief that you can
lock people up occupy them and of course
let's not forget Human Rights Watch
Amnesty International and others have
called what's happening in Palestine
apartheid that's their words every
Israeli human rights organization has
has called it a parthe if that is the
case for years and it is and I've
reported on that myself as I have other
journalists eventually people will snap
people will break you cannot continue to
behave like this as a Jewish State a
self-described moral State and expect
Palestinians simply to lie down and
accept it when you occupy a people for
that long look I don't accept and and
and support the idea of taking civilian
hostages at all condemn at 110% I'm not
defending that at all but it's used as a
bargaining chip you see one of the
problems so much and I've having
reported about this for so long is it's
the framing here that we can get
outraged in the west about the taking of
civilians back into Gaza fine but
there's far less outrage about the fact
that every day this year and for every
year for decades Palestinian civilians
are killed in the West Bank and Gaza
they are killed by Israeli forces that
gets far less International outrage now
they're both wrong killing civilians is
always wrong regardless of who does it
and where but ultimately to me I think
that double standing so much how we as
journalists report this is in my view a
big part of the problem and what the UN
calls the unlawful and illegal
occupation under international law but
to get us more informed for those who
are kind of in the gray Zone they hear
this term often Israeli Palestinian
conflict it's just a conflict we got so
many conflicts going on in the world
what's B deal with this and that's going
to be my first question to my guest is
this is this term Israeli Palestinian
conflict is this a fair and accurate way
to frame this issue among so many other
questions that I'm sure you guys have be
trying to ask ask him for you guys and
get his reaction to these with my next
guest let's bring him on out
the I love
you when I was ready about it I would
only I was explaining how much respect I
have for the faith of
Islam to the de show the de
show alayum greetings and peace how are
you doing Dr Omar alhamdulillah how are
you good alhamdulillah you already heard
my first question I put it out there did
you get to hear that I did did yeah um I
think that one of the main problems with
the framing of this is that it
intentionally sort of puts this on you
know equal power dynamics so you got two
equal opposing armies you've got two
equal opposing Nations you've got two um
you know peoples that have been at it
for for centuries and and one of the
things that Israeli propaganda takes
advantage of and honestly American
propaganda which is which an which is
basically an extension of Israeli
propaganda is that the public uh usually
doesn't read beyond the headline and so
it's hit people with these outrageous
headlines without
factchecking um emotional exploitation
and then sort of spin the the the the
entire crisis as oh these are just you
know two peoples that have been fighting
for thousands of years we're not going
to solve it now the reality is is that
um this is not a religious uh you know
conflict spanning f thousands and
thousands of years it's not like people
have been fighting Muslims and Jews all
this time over this land for thousands
and thousands of years this is an
illegal occupation that was an extension
of European
colonization of the land of Palestine
1948 and since then you've had a global
Refugee crisis since then you've had an
expanding illegal occupation if you put
up a map and you went and you showed the
expulsion of Palestinians from their
homes from 1948 until today there has
never been a period in which that has
stopped and in that process Palestinians
have been killed their movement has been
further restricted they are stateless
people if you're in Gaza in particular
60% of the population of of Gaza of Gaza
are actually refugees they were expelled
from other parts of Palestine into Gaza
so I have relatives in Gaza that I've
never even met they were expelled from
different parts of Palestine put into
this open air prison one of the most
densely populated areas in the world
with all freedom of movement restricted
being bombarded routinely with the most
sophisticated Weaponry in the world shut
off from all sides and you know the
daily incursions the daily aggressions
against the people of Gaza and the
people of Palestine as a whole go
completely ignored by the American Media
so something as simple as you know
gaza's sea ports constantly restricted
the only way that people can eat when
they are shut off from all the different
directions in terms of land is they're
fishing and so routinely you'll have
that radius shut down to where you know
you can no longer fish 11 miles out now
it's seven miles now it's five miles the
Restriction of movement the destruction
of the hospital infrastructure the
bombing of the Egyptian border which has
been closed on the people of Palestine
and so if you're if you're an American
and you're watching the news and you're
hearing um you know Netanyahu just
saying all innocent Palestinians or all
Palestinian Civ he never uses the word
innocent of course civilians in Gaza uh
were warning you to leave leave where
leave where you're in this tiny place
and the the only hope that you have is
that the bombing does not hit your
residential building and the only
calculation that you could possibly make
is do I go next door or not do do I
trust that you know based upon whatever
Randomness I can decipher from these
bombings is it going to be you know uh
my cousin's uh building or is it going
to be my building building next and this
is of course ignoring the settler
violence this is ignoring the apartheid
system that has been imposed on the
Palestinians a legal system or an
illegal system through legal terminology
classed as a parthe by International
consensus now so it's not a conflict you
don't have two peoples two states two
Nations on equal footing you have an
occupier and an occupi you have a
colonizer and you have a colonized and
all of that is important context and
what the you know the propaganda is
doing is it's not just selling you a lie
about what's happening now it's
completely intentionally ignoring the
past so that people can be emotionally
exploited as these war crimes play out
in real time right in front of our eyes
you mentioned the word aparti I want you
to break this down for some people
haven't even heard this word we heard we
hear this a lot and is this considered
also under international law this is a
crime Israelis rule over Palestinians
has been described as this also by the
South African Freedom Advocate and icon
Desman 2u you also have this being also
put out by US President Jimmy Carter
calling this an AP part tide I don't
think anyone could go to the West Bank
in Gaza or even to East Jerusalem and
see what's happening now to the
Palestinians that would disagree with my
use of the word apart and you also had
two leading human rights organizations
yes team and bestum amongst others so
the question is why is this term aparte
appropriate for this and what does that
mean aparti for the average person just
AP partti what what what does that mean
two separate laws for two separate
peoples you have one set of people that
live under an entirely different set of
restrictions they live literally behind
an apartheid wall uh every single
element of a Palestinian life is
controlled by their occupier they do not
have equal right to any form of
political participation and they are
completely shut out from being able to
control their own daily needs and and
and you know live like decent dignified
normal human beings I actually encourage
people because people don't read anymore
to go read the amnesty report on a
paride the Human Rights Watch report on
a partti and actually go through the way
that that legal determin ation was made
because it is that important every
single South African apartheid activist
starting not just with Desmond Tutu but
Nelson Mandela himself has said that
what is being done to the Palestinians
is in many ways even worse than what has
been done to the to to black people in
South Africa he said it's worse he said
this is Nelsa Mandela he saying this is
worse Desmond Tutu actually went to the
ter teritories and came back and said in
many ways this is worse Nelson Mandela
says our freedom is incomplete until the
Palestinians realize their freedom so
there's a deliberate misinformation
campaign again about the presence there
is a uh a deliberate exploitation of the
overall ignorance that people have of
what takes place on a daily basis
because they are intentionally kept in
the dark you don't see the daily
aggressions against the Palestinian
people on any mainstream Outlet I mean
Gaza is being bombed right now brutally
people are being slaughtered in the dark
and that's not even making it to the
mainstream press what do you think about
the daily incursions on Masjid AA and
the settlers burning homes and attacking
people and lynching people and you know
just the everyday humiliation of
occupation if that if if right now Gaza
is not on your screen then how is that
going to be on your screen and so there
is a deliberate exploitation again of
people's overall ignorance of what's
taking place on a regular basis and it's
playing on people's emotions you know we
you you just saw the entire
disinformation campaign that the
president himself the president himself
repeated a hoax the reporting by uh one
Israeli TV channel that 40 babies were
murdered by Hamas including being
beheaded uh makes a number of the front
pages we have asked on three occasions
uh the IDF to confirm they have not
confirmed this reporting don't read the
newspaper you're uninformed if you do
read it you're misinformed I was a CI
director we lied we cheated we steal
stole like about 40 beheaded uh children
what about the 400 plus children in Gaza
now that are confirmed dead that's not a
hoax they're not just decapitated
they're finding legs in some places arms
in some places I mean these people are
being bombed by American bombs and
that's not a hoax and the president of
the United States States could not even
say a word of sympathy you know about
Palestinian life so this is this is the
most blatant hypocrisy that I think
we've seen in a very long time in
regards to what is happening uh to the
Palestinian people it
resembles very much the the racist
islamophobic uh framings that that uh we
have been subjected to especially in the
immediate aftermath of 9/11
you know we're being portrayed as the
Arab Savages who are bloodthirsty and
cannot but be governed by brutality and
so the only way to deal with these you
know bloodthirsty Arab Muslims is to mow
the lawn is to carpet bomb them Ted Cruz
said turn it into a parking lot
Netanyahu uh is told by Jordan Peterson
give him hell uh Nikki Haley says finish
them right and and I'm probably
confusing at this point now who say said
what but it's just disgusting talking
points from the right and from the left
that are not even veiling the fact that
they don't view Palestinians as full
human beings and they're playing to that
imagination that these people are
bloodthirsty the only way you can deal
with them is put them in this tiny piece
of land shut off the water shut off the
electricity shut off the hospital system
shut off the fuel starve them to death
and bomb them with the most
sophisticated Weaponry that exists in
the world today targeted attacks on
civilian infrastructure with a clear aim
to cut off men women children of water
electricity and heating with the winter
coming these are acts of pure Terror and
we have to call it as such I want you to
think about how sick and demented that
is how sick and demented that is right
and the irony of it is that it's being
done in the name of protecting human
life that's the irony of it all this is
how you protect
lives so clearly you don't view all
human life as equal so at least be open
about your hypocrisy at least be open
about your double standards and stop
going about it in these two different
ways and and and just you know repeating
these horrific uh tropes about Arabs and
Muslims as if they're innocent well I
have a lot of questions you me mentioned
and I'll get to this the settler
situation the legal settlements um you
mentioned now the cutting off of food
basic food water you know the survival
for life so many questions and I want to
get this in a short amount of time we
have together uh but first I want to get
into I want to apologize Eddie I'm
jumping I'm jumping from place to
honestly this has been a very I'll be
very real with you um and I think it's
important yes we're not sleeping we're
not sleeping because we have relatives
we have people in Gaza that are cut off
right now and every morning you're
waiting to hear if they're alive or not
wow and while we're not sleeping we know
they're not sleeping now what we're
dealing with is nothing compared to what
they're dealing with the sad thing is
that you know to to see in these moments
that you know we have to fight not just
Israeli propaganda but the full thrust
of propaganda here at
home the political establishment the
media establishment your Brands your
celebrities your influencers it is
absolutely exhausting you know what's
happening with people at work you've got
now state governments uh like Texas just
put out some sort of a warrant or
creating uh some sort of a Division I
don't even know what it's called but to
monitor uh you know and surveil uh Pro
Palestinian um you know protests and
Report uh concerning Behavior so this is
if it seems like we're scattered right
right now and we're jumping from place
to place MH and we're outraged it's
because we are we actually are outraged
and we don't you know we don't even know
where to start when talking to people
because the depth of ignorance and media
manipulation is just that strong right
now tell tell me this um recently there
was a tweet that went out where Jordan
Peterson he tweeted give them hell and
this is kind of people were shocked
because it's kind of we've never heard
you to tell someone to go to hell so can
you tell us the uh and I did a program
on this can you go ahead and let us know
what was the obviously we can see the
buildup to it and can you go ahead and
elaborate on this well look um I think
it's important to recognize and and you
know every Tuesday night I do uh a class
called the firsts where I go through the
lives of the sahabah and it just so
happened we had just finished the um the
classes
about
many of the the of what's known
as and two massacres that happened right
in the aftermath of where more people
actually died or were killed martyred in
those two massacres in the immediate
aftermath of than itself there were more
shat from those two massacres than
itself and it was complete betrayal
ambassadors being killed people that
were guaranteed safety that were
ambushed and killed and the prophet
wasallam made Dua against those
murderers in every single Salah five
prayers for a month I want you to
imagine walking into the Masjid of the
Prophet Salli wasallam every single
Salah for an entire month the prophet
sallai wasallam raised his hands and he
made Dua against those people now we
know when the prophet sallam himself had
his teeth knocked down and was was
almost killed he
said forgive my people they don't know
any better the point is is that the
prophet s alaihi wasallam did make Dua
against oppressors he made Dua for the
guidance of even his worst enemies and
people that oppressed him in the most
significant of ways and he backed up
that Dua by forgiving those people
forgiving those people that killed his
own family that did things to him when
they sought forgiveness when they uh
came back to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam in a different state
than the one that they were in before
but the prophet Salli wasallam did make
Dua against tyrants the prophet Sall
wasallam did make Dua against oppressors
so this is a part of the Sunnah too so
it's interesting because and immediately
after I tweeted that I got all sorts of
messages she take that down it's not
befitting uh it's a it's it's it's a bad
look and this is uh you know this is not
the Sunnah I'm like no it actually is it
is the Sunnah sometimes to make Dua
against people and so I meant it as a
Dua against Jordan Peterson I really did
when you are to that level of hard
heartedness and evil to where you can
say give him hell to one of the worst
tyrants if not the worst Tyrant and
fascist in the world and you know
exactly what give him hell means it
means go mow the lawn in Gaza it means
go murder those animals animals in
quotation
marks because that's what they call them
in Gaza and you know that that's going
to result in what we're seeing right now
children being pulled out the rebel
there is Israel has done this too many
times in the past for us to have any uh
hesitation in knowing that this is
exactly what's going to happen right now
it's just more aggressive than before so
when when you as a person and you you
masquerade in the public as a thoughtful
human being as someone who cares about
you know uh people's well-being as
someone who whatever it is right you
masquerade in so many different
ways as the this thoughtful individual
but you put out something so evil
knowing the implications of it I meant
it as a Dua against him and I believe we
should and this is an important part of
our Sunnah make Dua against tyrants yes
make Dua for the guidance of people that
you know uh that just don't know any
better make Dua for the guidance you
know be have the heart to forgive people
and that's a part as well right you have
co-workers maybe you have colleagues
that just don't know any better talk to
them make Dua that Allah opens their
heart that Allah guides them it's very
hard for us sometimes to um to recognize
the depths of the ignorance that some
otherwise very good people have fallen
into but Jordan Peterson knows what he's
doing and those types of voices know
exactly what they're doing first of all
he's on the payroll of the daily wire so
that should that should have been no
secret for for many many months if not
years at this point as to what he was
about but when he does that honestly
um you know him and those like him
should be put in their place should be
absolutely put in their place this is
innocent life that we're talking about
right now and uh we should have very
little tolerance for those that have
dehumanized the most noble people on
Earth because the prophet sallai
wasallam talked about how Noble the
people on the outskirts OFA are within
AA and the outskirts of AKA are those
are the most noble people on Earth right
now and we should have no
tolerance with rhetoric that dehumanizes
them and we should take that to our Dua
that the voices of evil are silenced as
well that Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
either show them the error of their ways
or that Allah subhanahu wa taala you
know do with them as he sees fit right
so that's a part of the Sunnah as well I
want to get into this next I want to
build a framework here I want it just I
don't want to spend too much time on
this but I think it's very very
important because it dispels a lot of
the myths so this is a college a
professor uh showing people can go look
into to look his name up and they can
see when Muslims conquer Jerusalem
because this revolves around Jerusalem I
want to get your quick reaction before I
get into my next questions Cal goes
okay I want to meet some of the Jews
living in Jerusalem and sophronius goes
there are no Jews in
Jerusalem and the goes what do you mean
there's no Jews in Jerusalem the city is
Holy to the Jews how could there be no
Jews and he says well us Christians we
pretty much murder them every chance we
get we really hate Jews in fact in the
war we just did against the Persians the
Jews sided with the Persians and so we
murdered 20,000 Jews in Jerusalem and
completely purged the city of its
remaining Jewish
population and Omar
goes no this is wrong you can't do
this and so he turns to a convert to
Islam a Jewish convert to Islam and he
says I need you to find me 80 Jewish
families that were willing to volunteer
to move to Jerusalem so we can
reestablish a Jewish presence in this
city and
that's how the Muslims conquered
Jerusalem
and that's the stuff that's left out of
your history books what do you think
often there's this um misconception it's
Muslims they hate Jews they want to
annihilate Jews you hear this uh
rhetoric uh this is our history here
this is not coming from a Muslim this is
a university Professor following the
example of prophet muhammmad peace and
blessings be upon him when he came with
the army of 10,000 strong and he could
have obliterated all of the Pagan Arabs
at that time and others but he said
spread the peace spread the food Omar is
going the head of state at that time and
now he actually
repopulated this is like I I this blows
your mind salahudin Ubi came later he
did the same thing showing Mercy what do
you say when you see something like this
um look I think I think that one of the
most exhausting talking points is the
conflation of anti-zionism with
anti-semitism it is absolutely
nauseating it's
ahistorical it is um intentionally
ignorant and
reductionist you you just have to
completely ignore our history and ignore
who we are today to try to make that
conflation so there are historical
Jewish communities in the Muslim world
that were never annihilated
alhamdulillah there is a legacy of mercy
and Justice and
and as you mentioned when Muslims came
to Jerusalem uh even under you
know after having faced some of the
worst
brutality that human beings have ever
faced Salah did not enter Jerusalem
after you know uh peaceful Behavior
towards Muslims and then react in kind
Salah entered Jerusalem after the
Crusades who literally
you know roasted people at the St burnt
them at the stake and ate them who had
you know Muslims uh Orthodox Christians
and Jews
massacred by the hundreds of thousands
and the blood to the knees of their
horses uh the the crimes that were
committed against the Muslims and other
religious communities are well
documented and the mercy and the
maginity and the justice that was shown
by the likes of
Sal and there is so much more in our
Islamic history uh is well documented
this is it's it's ahistorical
reductionist ignorant and the conflation
is very much so intentional because uh
it try it it tries to remove the
criticism of the colonial ethn fascist
state of
Israel and
turn it into uh you know just Muslims
who hate Jews and that could not be
further from the truth and by the way
some of the most foremost voices for
justice for the Palestinians are young
Jewish Americans so it it just it's all
around incoherent and ignorant and
reductionist and
ahistorical uh you you can look through
our history and you can see many
examples not just you know the one that
was cited there even though there's you
know the way that the professor framed
it uh there are some you know
inaccuracies uh here there you
know returned some of the families that
were expelled so it wasn't just random
families the point being that we have a
sense of justice we have a framework in
Islam uh we reject tyranny no matter
what we reject tyranny and you know what
we reject it against ourselves as well
and we rejected against our Palestinian
brothers and sisters right now as well
and we will speak for them
because right now they are in a blackout
they are in a blackout and everything is
being taken away from them and so they
need us and and this is sort of I guess
take it as my parting message
um there's a lot of Despair there's a
lot of um hopelessness it feels like
we're getting punched in the face right
and left because you turn on the TV and
it's
infuriating uh you see your favorite
celebrity and athlete uh tweets on
something idiotic out it's infuriating
um you see the right and the left
political establishments somehow finds
agreements on the dehumanization of the
Palestinians it's exhausting you see the
recreation or well never really went
away the expansion of the surveillance
state right now against the Muslim
Community it's exhausting people are
going to lose their jobs you have these
uh weird watch lists that you know I
mean I can't tell you how many times any
you know University or anywhere else
gets contacted by these people these
lists are put together uh you even have
the CEO of a large hedge fund right that
is going after anyone who signs a prop
Palestinian letter an academic letter
all of this is happening right now but
you know what we cannot be silent we
can't be silent and we cannot say that
well it's too costly to raise our voices
right now because look what's happening
to the Palestinian people right now look
what's happening to them so let's draw
from their courage let's draw from
whatever strength they are mustering up
to be able to survive the nights of
bombardment with no basic necessities
and without the sympathy of the
developed world and let's instead be
their voices insh let's let's muster up
the courage to be able to face whatever
consequences come with that because
every single moment that you're raising
awareness whatever it is whatever
platform whatever small thing you think
you're doing you're fighting back
against this cruel narrative that has
very real consequences in real time
right now this is an emergency situation
so we need everyone to make Dua we need
everyone to raise awareness in every way
that they possibly can there's uh
there's a statement from this uh person
as a recent interview with Piers Morgan
he was interviewing Ben Shapiro and
quote he's saying only solution is for
Israel to Annex the Gaza Strip and kill
enough of the sons of [__] is his
quote anyone who calls for the ceasefire
is a terrorist sympathizer I want to get
into this clip and and get your reaction
to it in one of the videos you say the
only solution is for Israel to Annex the
Gaza Strip and kill enough sons of
[__] to make sure this isn't a
problem again you say anyone who calls
for a ceas fire is a terrorist
sympathizer under these circumstances
now that got a lot of push back uh I
guess this comes to the point of
appropriate response how far do you go
how do you isolate genuine Hamas from
perhaps completely innocent Palestinians
in Gaza of which there will be many um
one person called you a genocidal
warmonger for that rhetoric and there's
a a person called Muhammad hijab in a
video called in responding to benir on
Israel he says
this first and foremost I'll say yes we
condemn any woman child or whatever it
may be that's being killed who's Jewish
and who's not a non-combatant but why is
it the case Ben
huh why is it the case that you none of
your colleagues or you have been able to
offer one single condolence one single
condemnation one single word of sympathy
for any of the gazin that have been
killed don't try and smear us don't try
and slander us don't try and attack
don't try and produce red earrings and I
think you're an ass a jackass and we're
not talking about Hamas we're talking
about children here we're talking about
in here we're talking about elderly
people you make me sick you make me
sick what's your response to that Ben
that will be I'm sure a reaction You'
have heard from a lot of people what do
you feel about that I mean my obvious
response is of course I feel horrible
for the people who are being held by
Hamas in a state of tyranny for the past
15 years Kamas was the elected
government in Gaza in 2006 there has
hasn't been an election since then all
the people who are who are today ranting
as as you heard Muhammad hijab doing
right there I don't hear them talking
about liberating Gaza from Hamas which
is the greatest threat to the to the way
of life of gazin on planet Earth again
I've nothing but sympathy for Hamas for
for the people that Hamas is is
governing or the people that Hamas is
exploiting really I have nothing but
sympathy for civilians there Israel has
to defend itself I don't understand your
your
reaction I mean everything that Muhammad
said to him and more uh complete
sick twisted human being um you can see
the insincerity right in his eyes I
think that one of the things that we
have to do you know is take people back
to context the greatest threat to the
Palestinian people is the occupation of
the Palestinian people is the calls for
the annihilation of the Palestinian
people which has happened
uh through people like Shapiro and his
well-funded propaganda machine and
others like him that have openly called
for genocide they're not even hiding it
anymore and so I have nothing but
sympathy okay I mean it's it's very
clear that you have uh something other
than sympathy but you know why don't
they why don't why doesn't Piers Morgan
press him on this like they anytime a
speaker someone comes on you know from
the other side they really they start
off with this do you support what Hamas
launched do you condemn what Hamas did
how many times Israel have committed war
crimes do you start by asking them to
condemn themselves have you you don't
but he's kind of just you know stumbling
and he's not being direct you know I was
I it was interesting because I was
watching um you know uh CNN as uh I was
waiting for um you know the remarks of
Biden a few days ago
and they were interviewing person after
person um you know family after family
um about the horror of the attacks that
came from Gaza not a single family from
Gaza is being interviewed and when they
finally get a Palestinian on they
immediately go into do you condemn do
you condemn do you condemn do you
condemn what Hamas did you know they
someone says that I just lost 10
relatives 15 relatives we don't have an
Iron Dome we have nowhere to run to we
have absolutely no shelter we have no
humanitarian Aid the basic necessities
of life are cut off and immediately you
can see the antagonistic nature of
interviewers do you condemn uh towards
Palestinians and you can see the
dehumanizing
rhetoric barely masked even in you know
you know the voices of people that are
supposed to be seasoned media people
they can't even mask their their hatred
their disdain uh for the Palestinian
people and they keep playing to again
these tropes of the Arab Muslim
Savages um and so when someone talks
about you know threats to the
Palestinian people and you know uh yeah
this is this is the the greatest threat
to the people of Gaza is this the
greatest threat to the people of the
West Bank is this no the greatest threat
is the illegal occupation and system of
apartheid that was imposed upon them
none of this happens if you don't have a
people that are forcibly removed from
their homes put into uh you know these
these small areas open a prisons
bombarded routinely cut off from the
rest of the world stripped of their
citizenship and their entire identity
none of this happens if you don't do
that to a people and
so you know when people talk about
vicious cycle I'm just going to say it
like this the only way to end the
vicious ious cycle is to end the vicious
occupation any discussion that does not
include the ending of the illegal
occupation of Palestine is a worthless
discussion let me let me ask you this um
here you have an Irish I believe it's an
MP my question is how does are they just
more intelligent do they have access to
more information you're going to see
this short clip I'm going to get your
reaction to it but how do people in
certain congresses senates are they
deprived of what this man is informed to
if I was Jewish and had never stepped
foot in Israel I could claim citizenship
there tomorrow but 6 million people
whose Origins are in what you now call
Israel who were forced out in 1947 or 48
do not have that right isn't that part
of the reason why the Palestinians are
in dispute with Israelis because you
deny them the right to return to their
homes and to their land and their
Villages and that they have a legitimate
claim even under international law to
return but you deny them that right why
do you deny them that right and why do
you give that right to other people who
have no connection whatsoever with the
land whether you call it Israel or
whether you call it Palestine why do you
continue to seize land if you're serious
about Oslo and the two states solution
which under that agreement is land
designated to be Palestinian land
500,000 people most of which has taken
place since osow you allow that to
happen why do you allow it to happen if
you're serious about giving this land to
the Palestinians it's absolutely
extraordinary are you not just taking US
ambassador for idiots that you can say
with a straight face we're serious about
peace but while we're serious about
peace we're going to seize Palestinian
land and you expect the Palestinians to
sit back and do nothing about that now
you know what the Palestinian people
have been asking for far less even than
some people would ask for because I
believe the whole aarti system should be
dismantled but what they've asked for is
to lift the siege of Gaza just to lift
the siege of Gaza let them have an
airport let them have H ports let them
not be dictated to by a government for
whom they do not vote as to what can go
in and out of their territories whether
they will have power whether they will
have clean water whether they will have
medicine what makes you think you're
allowed have nuclear weapons and a
fourth biggest army in the world and
visit destruction on the the people of
Gaza but they have no right to defend
themselves they have no territorial sov
of the that land could you ask questions
please how do you justify that all right
how do you justify those double
standards very lastly Ambassador people
like Bishop tutu Nelson Mela and I would
certainly describe your state as a uh a
partiz state with different laws for
people depending on their race or
religion for example at checkpoints
going into the West Bank there's a
channel if you're Israeli or european
and there's a channel if you're Arab
just because you're Arab if you came
into D Arin and they stopped you and
said are you Jewish oh no sir you can't
come in through the same entrance uh as
Irish people or european people because
you're Jewish you would call that racism
and aparti you practice that with your
checkpoints and your military uh
barriers and your partiz wall how can
you justify is he is he getting Intel
that they're not I I don't uh I don't
understand he's using he's using common
sense and he's speaking with common
dignity um just it's
foundational dignity um that
unfortunately is locking from the
discourse in the United States and and
let's be real here I mean I want to say
two things here number one um you know
on a personal level um my parents are
both Palestinian refugees they were both
expelled from their homes my parents
actually met in the United States I'm in
the process I've been trying to
translate the Poetry that my mother may
Allah have mercy on her used to write
about Palestine I've posted some of it
um and about Bosnia as well you know
I've spoken to you about that um you
know because we grew up with that in the
background also and just the oppressed
peoples I've never been to
my parents' Homeland I've never been
allow entry uh into my ancestral homes
I've never been able to go and visit my
relatives there are people there that I
love as if I've grown up with uh with
them and I've only known them through
zoom and FaceTime and I'm I'm grateful
to Allah for that that we at least have
that level of connection because
obviously our parents used to have you
know the occasional letter writing
but the fact that people can be forcibly
removed from their homes and someone
from Long Island New York you are
stealing my house and if I don't steal
it someone else is going to steal it you
know can can walk into a home in
Jerusalem where you have a
generational family occupancy and throw
them out with absolutely no
repercussions in fact with the full
cover of the the iof um with the full
cover of the entire security apparatus
of Israel um if that's not outrageous to
any human being any human being I'm not
even talking about faith now I'm just
talking about basic dignity basic
Humanity if that does not enrage you you
have to actually analyze and assess your
own Humanity at this point if that does
not enrage you that that someone who has
abolutely no connection to this home can
take a first class ticket over and throw
families out of their
homes and here's the thing and this is
what I want to end on you talk about two
sets of information you talk about the
um you know sort of the polarization
that's taking place now right so you can
see if you watch media in some countries
it's like you're you're looking at as if
you're looking at two different regions
it makes no sense
right but here's what we also have to be
very very honest with these tactics are
the exact same tactics that tactics that
the United States government used in the
Iraq and Afghanistan Wars mhm the
dehumanizing of entire populations and
erasing their stories from the American
public and you know with the hundreds
and thousands of casualties ask an
American to name you one victim of the
Iraq War they can't they can't because
they're not people anymore they were
wiped out in the name of security in the
name of security completely wiped out
populations and the terror that was
inflicted in the quote unquote war on
terror on innocent
populations that were again framed as
Savages Arab Muslim Savages with all of
these tropes M this is the exact same
rhetoric and the exact same framing
that's used against the Palestinian
people I got two more questions and
we're going to conclude I want to
because um most um Americans we know as
Muslims we would never do something like
this I mean this is something but let
alone Americans uh are not found of
sending three point some billion uh of
their taxpaying money to go ahead and
now as you can see uh this is from a
Hamza zores um talking about this Siege
where you have two million people you
have 50% if I'm not um mistaken our
children so this is something where the
American public the American taxpayers
you know when you look look into this
now do they really want to starve a
people to death I mean these are these
are not
animals but with that being
said nothing nothing nothing like what
is being done to the people of razza
right now what is being done to the
people of razza right
now
is inhumane is not even a word for it
targeted attacks on civilian
infrastructure with a clear aim to cut
off men women children of water
electricity and heating with the winter
coming these are acts of pure Terror and
we have to call it as such and and the
the sad thing is is that you have people
that otherwise might seem like
reasonable um normal people that are
somehow justifying this I'm not talking
about the Ben shapiros and the Jordan
Petersons of the world talking about
just normal people that you expect
better from uh that that somehow have
been manipulated to the point that they
believe that this is okay to starve off
an entire population over 1 million
children and you've got Tik Tock videos
being made by Israeli settlers mocking
The Thirst of the
Palestinians um guys putting their faces
next to faucets and uh showing off the
plentiful supply of water knowing that
there are babies that will die from not
having access to water not because of a
drought due to some sort of natural uh
disaster occurrence but due to the
intentional shutting off of water from a
sick and
demented regime and that's the only way
that that you can describe them sick and
demented we're we're done we're out of
time we're going to end with this I want
people to imagine themselves in the
situation where you have complete
buildings with civilians in them being
destroyed families being annihilated a
complete genocide happening but if you
look at some of these videos people
they're hearing some Arabic being said
and you continue and I'll end with this
video the people still keep praising the
most high the creator of the heavens and
[Music]
earth
alhamdulillah
moment
[Music]
for Fore foreign
for
[Music]
what lesson can can
we take from that
sh the fact that these people can say
alhamdulillah is
uh I just want you to think about that
as as you complain about anything
happening in your life know I
yeah alhamdulillah all you can say is
alhamdulillah the fact that they can say
alhamdulillah with all that happening is
um is a great sign of Iman it's a
miracle of faith I just hope that you
know a lot of times we become
disconnected in our
um we become entirely disconnected from
from these people and when you forget
Allah you forget yourself and you forget
other
people
um you know the last conversation that I
had with um distant cousin of
mine uh before his his I don't know what
happened to his phone I just said you
know just um keep saying immediately
alhamdulillah the fact that these people
still say
alhamdulillah it is it is nothing short
of a miracle and it puts us to shame in
our own lives so be inspired by the
people of Raza as well thank you very
much may um creator of the heavens and
ner of God Almighty Allah bless you
and help all those who are suffering
and reward you and just thank
you our brother in Islam Eddie from the
dean show is creating the dean Center
which is a mjid and a DA Center which is
going to help non-muslims learn about
Islam inshallah and the most beautiful
thing about this is that we can all be a
part of this we can all take part in
earning rewards from this simply by
donating whatever we can to make this a
reality which is beautiful let's do that
all right let's click this link let's
donate what we can and let's make this a
reality
[Music]
inshallah I cannot leave without giving
you a gift if you're not yet Muslim and
you're tuning in to see what these
Muslims are talking about and you like a
free copy of the Quran go ahead and
visit theen show.com we'll take care of
the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions about Islam call us at 1
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum